- My name is Bryan
Stevenson, and I'm a lawyer,
an advocate and an activist
for ending mass incarceration
and creating racial justice in America.
- [Man] Racial justice in America,
creating racial justice in America.
(gentle, haunting music)
- [Bryan] I've been
trying to say something
about our criminal justice system.
Whenever you're talking about a violation
of basic human rights, a
violation of basic human dignity,
your first requirement is to make sure
people see the humanity of the people,
who are experiencing these injuries.
(gentle, haunting music)
In this country, we
don't talk about slavery,
we don't talk about lynching,
we don't talk about segregation
and we don't wanna talk about racial bias
in our criminal justice system.
If we're serious about
correcting the imbalance
created by decades of
inequality and injustice,
we have to do more than just be silent.
(gentle, quirky music)
- [Man] I've been trying
to say something about
criminal justice system,
say, say something
about criminal justice,
I've been, I've been--
this country is very different today,
than it was 40 years ago.
In 1972 there were 300,000
people in jails and prisons.
Today there are 2.3
million, million, million,
million, million, million, million.
(hammering gavel)
The United States now has the highest rate
of incarceration in the world.
We have seven million people
on probation and parole
and mass incarceration,
incarceration, incarceration.
It's fundamentally changed our world.
In poor communities and
communities of color,
there is this despair,
there is this hopelessness,
that has been shaped by these outcomes.
One out of three black men
between the ages of 18 and 30
is in jail, in prison,
on probation or parole.
One out of, one out of, one
out of, one out of three, three, three, three,
black, black, black, black,
prison, prison, prison, prison,
probation, probation, probation,
parole, parole, parole.
I've been trying to say something
about our criminal justice system.
(gentle, quirky music)
Our system isn't just
being shaped in these ways,
that seem to be distorting around race,
they're also distorted by poverty.
We have a system of
justice in this country,
that treats you much better
if you're rich and guilty,
than if you're poor and innocent.
The opposite of poverty is not wealth.
The opposite of poverty is justice.
Try to, try to, try to, try to,
say something, say something,
try to, try to, try to, try to,
say something, say something.
I've been trying to say something
about our criminal justice system.
The United States is the
only country in the world
where we sentence 13-year-old children,
where we sentence, sentence, United States
country in the world, sentence children,
13-year-old children, the United
States, the United States.
The United States is the
only country in the world
where we sentence 13-year-old
children, that die in prison.
We have life in prison without parole
for kids in this country.
Only country in the world.
We love innovation; we love technology;
we love creativity; we love...
But ultimately, those
realities, realities, realities,
are shadowed by suffering,
abuse, degradation,
marginalization, and for me,
it becomes necessary to integrate the two,
because ultimately we are
talking about the need
to be more hopeful, more
committed, more dedicated
to the basic challenges of
living in a complex world.
To me, that means spending time
thinking and talking about
the poor, the disadvantaged.
I've come to understand and to believe,
that each of us is more
than the worst thing we've ever done.
(gentle, quirky music)
- I think the character of any society,
its commitment to justice, its
commitment to the rule of law
has to be evaluated not by
looking at how it treats
the rich and the powerful
and the privileged,
but by looking at how it treats the poor
and the incarcerated, the disfavored,
people living in the margins of society.
Our response to them,
our relationship to them
reveals our true character.
I think there's something better
waiting for people in this
country than what we’ve experienced.
There's something more genuinely free,
more genuinely equal, more genuinely just,
than what we've
experienced in this country,
and if we desire it
and we struggle for it,
we can achieve it.